Gaurav Subedi: Renee, are you here?
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Yes.
Gaurav Subedi: It sent you a test email, did you get it?
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Study?
Gaurav Subedi: It sent you a testament.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: It says it's expired. Oh, okay. Yeah, it's sent.
Chad Nicely: Adarsha's… is Adarsha here? Okay, do we have everybody here? Alright, here's the deal. When you're done with this, Renee, can you make sure that the team call always records on its own? Can you do that?
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Yes.
Chad Nicely: Okay.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Didn't it record at first?
Chad Nicely: Huh?
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Or, did you manually press record?
Chad Nicely: Yeah, I manually did it.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Oh, hook.
Chad Nicely: Because it was not recording.
Chad Nicely: Alright guys, so here's the deal.
Chad Nicely: Everybody's in that Telegram room now, yeah?
Hannah: Yes.
Chad Nicely: Okay.
Chad Nicely: So every morning, I want to plan out the day, and what's gonna happen is, we call our telegram Pacino. Pacino's gonna go look at the notes from the call, and there is a, task board, and it keeps track of everybody's progress, and their problems, and their notes, and what they got done, and everything else.
Chad Nicely: So, at that time, I'll drop a link in the chat. I'll say, alright, everybody, join the call. You'll go to the same link, boom, we'll be on the call, it'll record it, it'll grab the transcript, it'll update the boards. Guys, my goal is for this thing to tell us what we need to be doing.
Chad Nicely: I want to wake up every morning and say, okay, Pacino, what do we gotta do? Well, Ahmad's gotta finish the API docs, and Darsh is working on the front layouts for the quizzes, and you see what I'm saying? That's what I want to do. Make sense?
Chad Nicely: So, I'm out to prove in the marketplace that this thing is a CEO. I'm the only one trying to do this.
Chad Nicely: I'm the only one actually doing anything. So I want to prove that this thing is the CEO, okay? So, every morning, we'll talk about what we gotta get done, and then at nighttime, when we have our recap, you might not be on that call, Hannah, we'll talk about everything that we did, and then whatever notes come up for the next day that continue. Make sense?
Hannah: Yes.
Chad Nicely: Alright, good. So, everybody's in that room. Now, I told that thing yesterday to make sure that it listens to, what you guys are… have it send it to CNicely32, Pernay. Chat at ChadNicely.com does not work on Mailgun for some reason.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: book.
Chad Nicely: And it can send it to you, too, it doesn't have to send it just to me.
Chad Nicely: Guys, everything we're doing manually, loading replays, right now, Pranay's sending out an email, all of this stuff.
Chad Nicely: I want it done in the team room. Now, right now, we're starting out with one room.
Chad Nicely: what's gonna happen is, we're gonna create agents inside of OpenClaw, and we're gonna have some agents that are good at writing emails, good at sales copy, then we're gonna have other agents that are good at support, good at this, and each agent's gonna have its own room, and then we're gonna be inside that room. Does that make sense?
Chad Nicely: How about everybody else?
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah?
Ammad Sarfraz: Yes.
Chad Nicely: This is where, we have to get to… I don't see the test yet, Rene.
Chad Nicely: What's the.
Gaurav Subedi: Justin, so maybe just wait a bit.
Gaurav Subedi: Sending to Synag C3 now… Okay, it just changed.
Chad Nicely: Okay, hold on.
Chad Nicely: It's usually pretty fast.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: It says API source success, but I haven't received it yet.
Chad Nicely: You haven't received what?
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: the email?
Chad Nicely: Are you looking at C92?
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: No, I asked to send to myself.
Gaurav Subedi: Also, Ahmad, you are seeing those messages there, right?
Ammad Sarfraz: On the Telegram.
Ammad Sarfraz: Yep.
Chad Nicely: It's usually pretty fast, I don't think it's actually sending, guys.
Gaurav Subedi: And would it use that endpoint? It just said it's sending from Broadcast email, send email.
Gaurav Subedi: That's how it would send the test email as well, right?
Chad Nicely: There it is, I got it.
Ammad Sarfraz: Boom.
Chad Nicely: I got it. Okay.
Chad Nicely: Is it called…
Gaurav Subedi: work, then.
Chad Nicely: Is it called, This is Unfair?
Gaurav Subedi: Is that one the right one to name?
Chad Nicely: That was February 14th.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: No.
Chad Nicely: That's right.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: The subject is 10AM PST.
Chad Nicely: No, I don't have it.
Chad Nicely: Okay, send that.
Gaurav Subedi: You are saying the body structure that you sent, right? Is that right? Like, the type would be test, test email would be the one that we want to send it to?
Ammad Sarfraz: Yes, it should send the test email.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay, so maybe we just wait a bit, right?
Chad Nicely: It's usually pretty fast, G.
Chad Nicely: It's only sending one email.
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, it's still sad, maybe sometimes the email provider is slow.
Gaurav Subedi: Because the API is right, and everything is right, so… Just wait a minute.
Gaurav Subedi: run a check spams as well, maybe it could go to… just make sure.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Yeah, I've checked, but I didn't receive.
Gaurav Subedi: also do this, go into global control manually.
Gaurav Subedi: Type in a separate email, like, you would recognize, and then send a test to yourself.
Gaurav Subedi: If that arrives and this didn't, then it's not working.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Yeah.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, I don't think it's sending, guys.
Chad Nicely: I've done lots of tests, usually pretty fast. Okay, so…
Gaurav Subedi: Said, what are you sending me?
Chad Nicely: That's the stuff we'll set up for Nick's company, for… that's his Telegram bot token.
Gaurav Subedi: I still gotta do everything else. I still gotta go take chat. You could do it for me.
Chad Nicely: We need to chat at selfmasteryCo.com.
Chad Nicely: Get the API key for Claude, get the AP key for the moon thing, get the agent email address.
Chad Nicely: What else do we need? The Whisper API key.
Chad Nicely: Right? That's it. I'll give you a profile for Self Mastery Code, we'll set up the hosting today.
Chad Nicely: And then I want to get that team where they're talking inside of a Telegram room, and Hannah can help them get training there so that they're writing emails, building courses, doing all that stuff. Yeah?
Gaurav Subedi: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Because Nick's got a big AI audience, and he needs to be able to say, my companies are running on this technology, right? He just went into his WhatsApp group, an AI Whats group, an AI WhatsApp group of 900 people, and said, who wants Chad to help you with this? And it blew up. There's, like, over 50 responses so far.
Chad Nicely: We need to set him up today, plus it's gonna help that company. But, while you guys are looking in the email, per day, the main thing is that we get it sent out.
Chad Nicely: So, if we can't send it out right now with OpenClaw, we gotta find out why, because I gotta demonstrate that today on the call, guys.
Chad Nicely: Like, I have… I have to show it sending email today, right?
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah.
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, that's what he's testing real quick, and… are we gonna buy the VPS ourselves for self-master?
Chad Nicely: Yeah, just… just buy it yourself.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay.
Chad Nicely: You have the card and everything.
Ammad Sarfraz: Gaurav, I think it is… it's not sending the… I will check again, but it's not sending the, the key for sending, for the standing schedule. It should be test. It's not sending that, not setting up the…
Ammad Sarfraz: that property… So it's not so…
Gaurav Subedi: avoiding.
Ammad Sarfraz: As of them, maybe.
Ammad Sarfraz: Yeah, in the body.
Ammad Sarfraz: Because what it's saying…
Gaurav Subedi: Is it, is it on the dog, though?
Gaurav Subedi: Have you mentioned that on the talk?
Hannah: Nice, yeah.
Ammad Sarfraz: I have mentioned it at all.
Gaurav Subedi: Send email, right?
Chad Nicely: Alright, while you guys are figuring that out, Ishwar, what do you have on your plate?
Ishwor Shrestha: Right now, I'm making chunks of customer on Core Sprout.
Chad Nicely: You're doing what?
Ishwor Shrestha: Making chunks of Core Sprout. Customer.
Chad Nicely: Of course, I don't know what that means.
Chad Nicely: I don't know what that means. Chunks of coarse sprout?
Ishwor Shrestha: Customer.
Chad Nicely: What about the customer?
Gaurav Subedi: Oh, he's talking about Chad, on the self-mastery account, they are sending the… I think Keith is sending the re-engagement emails, right?
Chad Nicely: Keith is sending what?
Gaurav Subedi: re-engagement emails?
Chad Nicely: Yeah, he doesn't need to do that. You don't need to be doing any re-engagement, Ishwar.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay.
Chad Nicely: What I need Ishwar doing is building out apps, guys.
Chad Nicely: I need him building out apps. So you're done with the container one, yeah?
Ishwor Shrestha: Yeah.
Gaurav Subedi: For the front end, he's done, and then, yeah, he can work on something else.
Chad Nicely: Alright, then what I'm gonna do… how familiar are you with all this Claude code and all this API stuff? Are you getting pretty familiar, or no?
Ishwor Shrestha: Yes, sir. It is easier.
Chad Nicely: Is it getting easier?
Ishwor Shrestha: Yes, sir.
Chad Nicely: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Bye-bye.
Gaurav Subedi: But I think I see the problem on the endpoint.
Gaurav Subedi: I got the email from GC?
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, I think we saw the problem. Ahmad, on that JSON body response that bot gave.
Gaurav Subedi: It doesn't have the tag, right? It has to either have an activity or a tag to start the send email, right?
Gaurav Subedi: Even on the UI side.
Gaurav Subedi: I think it's missing that, and it just skipped one property there.
Gaurav Subedi: Likewise, the same type?
Gaurav Subedi: Right?
Ammad Sarfraz: Yeah.
Ammad Sarfraz: Yes, I, I can test that, I… just a minute, because I…
Ammad Sarfraz: I guess it should be the,
Ammad Sarfraz: Give me a minute, let me see in the code, because I guess it is… the property…
Chad Nicely: Every day, send it out manually, okay?
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, the property is send… sending a schedule. That could be either immediate or test, right?
Ammad Sarfraz: Yeah, right.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay, so it's… it put the tag ID as null, and then it didn't do anything after that. Okay, so it's clearly missing the endpoint.
Chad Nicely: How far did we get with the FlexiFunnels one, the lead thing, Ishwar? Do you remember that lead platform you were doing? Are you done with that?
Ishwor Shrestha: I think, we need to make, authentication for that.
Chad Nicely: Okay, so you work on that today, yeah?
Ishwor Shrestha: Okay, okay, sir, but, I think we need a way to log in from the GC.
Ishwor Shrestha: For that app, right?
Chad Nicely: So, Coffee can work with you on that today, right, Coffee?
Chad Nicely: Coffee?
Chad Nicely: You see here?
Gaurav Subedi: Is he not on the call? He's not on the call.
Gaurav Subedi: I just invited him.
Gaurav Subedi: Ahmad, I think, for that missing endpoint, like, missing fields, you should send back an error.
Gaurav Subedi: It got success, so it just left it. It didn't even dry after that.
Ammad Sarfraz: Yes, give me a minute, I'm taking the code.
Ammad Sarfraz: That… should it be the checking for the tag or not?
Ammad Sarfraz: Tis,
Ammad Sarfraz: Because, this is what Kafi had worked on the broadcast, he knows… Better?
Ammad Sarfraz: Schedule thing that, so I… the broadcaster… .
Gaurav Subedi: Kathy, are you here?
M. A. Kafi: Yes.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay, you remembered, isol was working on that Flexifunnel code with the VIP code, you remember that?
M. A. Kafi: Yeah?
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, and he was trying to connect with GC, and we didn't have the endpoint for those, right?
M. A. Kafi: Yes.
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, so can you work with him today on GC, so he can do all of that?
M. A. Kafi: Okay.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay, and other thing is, Kafi, you are on Telegram, right? You are seeing the messages?
M. A. Kafi: Yes.
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, so the question is, do you see that body structure it sent?
Gaurav Subedi: We're missing the send… sending schedule type.
Gaurav Subedi: It can be either immediate or test, I think, right?
M. A. Kafi: I need to check the…
M. A. Kafi: Code, so that I can confirm.
Ammad Sarfraz: Yeah, Gaurav, it is that it doesn't matter if the tag ID is sent or not. For the testing, it should be…
Ammad Sarfraz: Their properties should be sent to test.
Ammad Sarfraz: Sending schedule should be sent to test. I just plugged in the…
Ammad Sarfraz: In the code, and two properties are needed for the test.
Ammad Sarfraz: One is the sending schedule, and the other is test email.
Ammad Sarfraz: So, it is… Yeah, it is setting the test email, but it is not sending the other property.
Gaurav Subedi: schedule. And if you don't set any of them, does it send back an error?
Gaurav Subedi: Or is it still success?
Ammad Sarfraz: it sends an error. If… Sending email… Yeah, if… No, it's,
Ammad Sarfraz: Sending email, test and no response, or filter.
Ammad Sarfraz: I think it should throw an error of input test email.
Gaurav Subedi: And, okay, tell me the values. One is immediate, another one is just test.
Chad Nicely: Okay, hold on a second, because this is not how I want this call to go, so hold on. Hannah, is everything good with you?
Hannah: Yes, I think so.
Chad Nicely: Okay, perfect. So we're gonna set up that Telegram room in that new company, and I need you to help those guys. Like, we gotta get away from manual stuff, right? Sending out emails, giving access in Core Sprout, creating courses, loading replays, all that stuff I need to happen on the next company, okay?
Hannah: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Alright, perfect. Ishwar, you know what you gotta do, you can get with coffee, he can set up that authentication for you.
Chad Nicely: Darsha, I had Vivid create 3 templates to make sure everything was gonna work with what you did. When I looked at it on mobile, they looked horrible. So I'm gonna try to work with you today. We gotta space out the buttons, we gotta center things.
Chad Nicely: And I need a more… I need a better look. It's not so much the fancy designs or whatever. It just needs to be the clean, like, what you see in, like, Typeform and stuff like that. Does that make sense? Like, get on YouTube, look at Typeform.
Chad Nicely: Look at how they're doing their surveys. They're super, super clean, they're clean on mobile. I don't need all the fancy shapes and buttons and everything, that doesn't matter, right?
Adarsha Shrestha: Okay.
Chad Nicely: So, I'll try to work with you on that today, so that we can find solutions to that, but he's got everything mapped. So, go try to connect one of yours, make sure you're good, make sure you understand, and then start working on the layouts, okay?
Chad Nicely: Alright, and then coffee, I need you to set up the, schedule broadcast today, and I need you to work with Ishwar in whatever order you want, okay?
M. A. Kafi: Mmm, the schedule, Amit may understand better, like, how the schedule work.
M. A. Kafi: And for the authentication, like.
Chad Nicely: Well, start with the authentication, then. I don't have time, I gotta get on a call, Kofi. Start with the authentication with Ishwar. When I get off my call, then we can visit with Ahmad and see what we can do on the schedule, okay?
M. A. Kafi: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Alright, bye-bye. Alright, so Kafi, Adarsha, Hannah, Ishwar, you guys can take off. Ahmad, G, Pranay, keep fixing this issue, please.
Ishwor Shrestha: Okay.
Adarsha Shrestha: vice versa. Okay.
Chad Nicely: Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
Hannah: Bye-bye.
Chad Nicely: Bye-bye.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay,
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, so Ahmad, can you see the responses that Bart is giving?
Gaurav Subedi: We're trying to make the bot work, so it's just saying that it returns success as true.
Gaurav Subedi: Count is 0, which is suspicious.
Gaurav Subedi: And it doesn't know what the value is, right? So we gotta work on some new things. One is the dock is incomplete on this stuff.
Gaurav Subedi: Like, when you're unsend, it should say what property you can use over there, right?
Ammad Sarfraz: Yeah?
Gaurav Subedi: So maybe you can just throw it on the AI?
Gaurav Subedi: You can ask the cloud coder, anything, whatever you want to do.
Gaurav Subedi: The doc needs to be a bit descriptive on the left side, right? Where you just have the endpoint name.
Gaurav Subedi: So let's try to do that. And for now, we can fix this one, though.
Gaurav Subedi: You can just… because this is our bot, and this is exactly what Chad's gonna use, we can just fix this here, right? So, it's asking, is sending scheduled tests required for the test email? Can you read those messages? You can actually reply to it, just mention the bot name.
Gaurav Subedi: And then reply to do whatever you want. Can you do that?
Ammad Sarfraz: Yeah, I'm seeing this. I'm seeing this.
Gaurav Subedi: Let's talk to this bot and tell it what it needs to do, so it learns that.
Gaurav Subedi: And then, Chad can do the demo, right? Because we have the call in, like, 3 minutes, exactly.
Ammad Sarfraz: Okay.
Chad Nicely: So it still has problems, G?
Gaurav Subedi: It doesn't have problem, the only thing it's missing is what it needs to use on that endpoint, the send email. That's the only problem. Everything else is working.
Chad Nicely: You've got time, because we're gonna train it for, like, a good hour, right?
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, but still, we're on the call right now, right? So we can discuss on what's going on, and we have 3 minutes, so let's do that.
Ammad Sarfraz: Hmm.
Gaurav Subedi: Hailing me up to this skill.
Gaurav Subedi: top level.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Yeah, I got the email.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay.
Gaurav Subedi: It's working now and then.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: But it's adding some question mark.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: I got to.
Gaurav Subedi: in the body.
Ammad Sarfraz: Yeah, it's working. Yeah. Thank you.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: I think the emojis, it's not able to…
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Send it properly, and it's replacing it with question mark.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay, Ahmad, can you say over there, can you send me that test email as well, and give it the email?
Ammad Sarfraz: Sorry?
Gaurav Subedi: And that message where you… where you just talked, just say, can you send me that HTML as well, and follow up with the…
Gaurav Subedi: Your email, so it can send you the test email, right?
Ammad Sarfraz: So you can take the copy.
Gaurav Subedi: We're good for now, we can test it with this, but when it uses the body, like, when it sends the email body, maybe something's happening, we can check that.
Gaurav Subedi: Renee, you already gave it the email body?
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Yes.
Gaurav Subedi: Let's see…
Gaurav Subedi: Okay, yeah, it's time for the call.
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, let's see real quick if Ahmad gets the email, and then we can get on that call.
Gaurav Subedi: Sending this email.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay.
Gaurav Subedi: Let's send it. Can you zig now?
Ammad Sarfraz: I, you received an email, but…
Ammad Sarfraz: It's question marks on the…
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, so that's the problem. I guess that's… those are the emojis or something, and then it couldn't pass it, or what have.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: I've been reading.
Pranay Rajopadhyaya: Yeah, it's the emoji.
Chad Nicely: I suggest you guys get on your own call. I gotta go do this thing.
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, I think we're done, Sadie, it's working.
Chad Nicely: Alright, you should probably attend the first part of the call then, Ahmad, so you can see, okay?
Ammad Sarfraz: Okay.
Chad Nicely: I'm gonna… let me just… let me just say this to you guys. This is… this is what I was trying to tell you, Ahmad.
Chad Nicely: If I show you this here, do you see this right here?
Chad Nicely: You see this page?
Ammad Sarfraz: Cheers.
Chad Nicely: All I did, all I did was type in a command, and it built this page.
Ammad Sarfraz: Right.
Chad Nicely: is doing it, Lovable's doing it, Base44 is doing it, they're all doing it. This is the level of stuff that people are expecting us to create right now. No more manual code.
Chad Nicely: None.
Ammad Sarfraz: Yep.
Chad Nicely: Beautiful designs, simple prompts, creating pages, creating surveys… this is the level we have to get to. Do you understand?
Chad Nicely: No more manual code, those days are over.
Ammad Sarfraz: Right.
Chad Nicely: Everybody, when they hire somebody now, they expect them to know how to do AI coding.
Chad Nicely: And it came overnight, but it's here. And if we don't catch up, like, Perry is doing this, Russell's doing this, everybody's doing it except us. So, I can't afford to pay people to do traditional code, traditional broken code anymore. I can't. I won't.
Chad Nicely: I won't.
Chad Nicely: Right? So, let's figure this out. I have a big opportunity out there with this open claw thing, I'm the leader in it right now, but now people are gonna jump in our tech, and we need to be showing that we are the best.
Chad Nicely: Okay? Yeah, right. So we'll visit on this later, but I wanted you guys to see that, alright?
Ammad Sarfraz: Yeah, that's fine.
Chad Nicely: Alright, I'll see you guys on the call.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay, bye-bye.